welcome to beyond Corp in a bottle where
we explore journeys into the world of
context to our access and zero trust
networks most companies look at security
as a binary with the good folks on the
inside and the bad folks kept outside so
security teams install various firewalls
and VPN tools to create a strong
perimeter always looking for taller
thicker walls to respond to the last
type of attack or compromise but this
model breaks down as soon as things get
more complicated employees have to work
outside contractors need access to just
one or two internal systems not all of
them mobile devices aren't compatible
with your VPN client and attackers are
sneaking into your network on previously
trusted devices hiding inside like a
Trojan horse we've seen the reinforced
perimeter model break down in many ways
exposing the highly vulnerable interior
so at Google we shifted to a model
without an insight or an outside we
reevaluate the trust of each request as
it is made and test to see if we should
grant access all access to company
resources gets decided based on the
context of the request who is it and
should they see this thing what device
are they on and do I consider that safe
if the identity plus device plus access
policy I'll check out then they get in
if not it's an express bus to 403 town
permission denied in this model there's
no trust inherent to any network or
location so we don't care if you're
sitting at home at a coffee shop we're
at the office you get exactly the same
level of access and it's easy to start
down this path on Google cloud platform
with identity or air proxy all you need
is an app that's using compute engine
App Engine or kubernetes Plus Google
identities for your employees and you
can start securing your apps with
identity controls to get more detail
check out my post link below and
subscribe to get more videos on beyond
Corp zero trust and identity wear proxy
when it comes to protecting your company
keep your data yours
you